- Let's descend into the
mouth of Hell, shall we?
(sinister music)
- [Nun] These sessions are
mandatory for all staff,
Sister Ann.
- My mother struggled
with depression.
(knocking)
- [Mom] Annie.
Annie, honey, can I come in?
- [Ann] But, even as a child,
I knew it was...
- [Mom] Annie open the door,
please.
- More.
(door knob rattling)
- [Mom] Let me in, Annie!
Let me in, Annie!
- [Ann] My mother talked about
hearing that voice inside.
- [Mom] Let me in, Annie!
Let me in!
(girl screams)
- [Ann] She said the voice
didn't really want her.
- [Priest] The Citadel has
fallen.
Black smoke blots out the sun.
Because as some of you may
already know,
we have a female student
in the class.
Only as an observer.
So, let's descend into the
mouth of Hell, shall we?
There are more possessions
reported today,
than at any other time
in history.
So, we must fight for
every soul.
- [Priest 2] Defend us in battle
against the spirits of
wickedness.
(bones crunching)
(girl snarls)
- [Natalie] Let me in!
- [Ann] I believe the demon
that is tormenting Natalie,
and the demon
that possessed my mother
are one and the same.
- [Priest] I'd like to teach
Sister Ann,
just enough to protect herself
and others.
This relationship she had,
it's personal.
- We've been waiting for you.
(ethereal singing)
Your mother has a pretty voice.
(door slams)
- [Ann] Hello?
- Let
me
in!
- [Priest] Be careful.
Once you know the devil,
- [Whispered Voice] Annie.
- [Priest] the devil knows you.
(Ann screams)
(strained gasping)
(ethereal singing)